well as we've been hearing world leaders
are gathering in new york climate action
very much at the top of their agenda but
are these meetings coming too little
too late well i want to bring back in
here our data dashboard in particular
looking here at this this is 11 years
and four months that takes us to january
2033 before we hit that one and a half
degree
target so with that in mind i really
like to start by asking uh by asking you
mikhail 2050 it's too late isn't it
2050 is way too late everything that
ticks on that board
is another fraction of a degree um is
another centimeter of rising sea levels
is another flood is another hurricane is
more lives and livelihoods lost
if we were to end slavery would we say
let's end it in 30 years no this is
about cutting everything right now as
quickly as possible
and michael uh the un says that even if
countries stick to the pledges that they
have made temperatures will rise by 2.7
degrees by the end of the century what
does a world look like with temperatures
but higher by 2.7 degrees
well we don't want to find out um that's
a world where you know you can imagine
the hottest day you've ever
experienced in your life and that may be
a typical summer day if we can you know
continue down this path and you know the
most extreme weather events the
devastating weather events that we're
now seeing play out the super storms the
wildfires they'll become that more
frequent they'll become that more
devastating so we don't want to find out
and that's why it's so important that
you know we not kick the can down you
know the road several decades as mccall
said we need to make sure that we
decarbonize our economy now
yeah and mikhail
no
major emitters
have a climate pledge that keeps them to
that one and a half degree target some
are close but the u.s for example is a
long way off
so we have two problems we have a
commitment gap so the promises that we
made are not good enough to get us to
where we need to but then also we have
an implementation gap even those that
make those commitments aren't taking us
uh far enough down the road and that is
true for uh all industrialized nations
and that is a a huge problem that we
need to tackle right away
some of the leadership that the uk has
to show now as the call president is
riling up those commitments but also
making sure that governments around the
world are living up to their commitments
sorry to interrupt you there michael the
other big gap michael is of course the
finance pledges 100 billion dollars a
year that was agreed more than a decade
ago in copenhagen by today's money that
would be 127 billion so is 100 billion
even ambitious enough
well maybe not but it's a foot in the
door and there's no question we have to
provide incentives to developing
countries to india to some of the south
american countries africa
we can't afford for them to make the
same mistake that we in the industrial
world made we can't afford for them to
industrialize their economy by uh you
know by burning fossil fuels and so we
have to provide incentives that make it
an easy decision for them to leapfrog
past the fossil fuel stage embrace
renewable energy build clean energy
infrastructure to develop their
economies yeah but i mean the us isn't
isn't doing their part of the bargain
here though are they recent uh estimates
suggest that the united states is only
providing four percent of its fair share
of that finance a long way to go
yeah well make no mistake about it uh
look we've seen some great pledges from
the current administration uh there are
certain
actions that the administration can take
executive actions but congress does
control the
string so ultimately we are going to
need congressional support that codifies
these commitments and as we speak we're
still
contending with this infrastructure
package and in particular reconciliation
package in congress where all of the
climate action really lies and we don't
yet have the votes to pass that even
with democratic control of congress and
so there's a lot of work to be done here
but the administration alone can't do it
we do need legislation that will codify
these efforts